De lo que quiero hablar es, como trasfondo,
es la idea de que los coches son arte.
Esto es en realidad bastante importante para mí,
porque los diseñadores de coches tienden a estar un poco bajos en el tótem,
no hacemos libros de mesa con una única lámpara dentro,
y se piensa tanto en los coches como producto
que es un poco difícil discutir el aspecto estético
con la misma terminología que uno usaría para el arte.
Así que los coches, como arte, traen esto a un plano emocional -- si lo aceptas --
que tienes que tratar al mismo nivel que usarías para el arte con A.
En este punto vais a ver una foto de Miguel Ángel.
Esto es completamente diferente a los automóviles.
Los automóviles son cosas que se mueven por sí mismas, ¿no? Los ascensores son automóviles.
Y no son muy emotivos, sirven a un motivo,
y ciertamente los automóviles han estado a nuestro alrededor durante 100 años
y han hecho de muchas maneras que nuestras vidas funcionen mucho mejor,
también han sido un auténtico dolor de muelas.
Porque los automóviles son en realidad la cosa que tenemos que solucionar.
Tenemos que solucionar la contaminación, tenemos que solucionar los atascos --
pero no es eso lo que me interesa en esta charla.
Lo que me interesa en esta charla son los coches. Los automóviles pueden ser lo que usas,
pero los coches son, en muchos sentidos, lo que somos.
Y mientras podamos solucionar los problemas de los automóviles,
y creo que podemos, con pilas de combustible o hidrógeno, como las que BMW está fomentando entusiastamente,
y montones de otras cosas, entonces creo que podemos mirar más allá
y tratar de entender por qué este anzuelo está en muchos de nosotros --
de esta "cocheidad" -- y lo que esto significa, lo que podemos aprender de ello.
Ahí es a donde quiero llegar. Los coches no son un traje,
los coches son un avatar, los coches son una expansión de tí mismo,
toman tus pensamientos, tus ideas, tus emociones, y las multiplican --
tu rabia, lo que sea. Es un avatar.
Es un súper Waldo en el que resulta que estás dentro, y si te sientes sexy,
el coche es sexy. Y si estás lleno de furia al volante,
tienes un "Chevy: Como una roca", ¿verdad?
Los coches son una escultura -- ¿lo sabían?
Que cada coche que veis ahí fuera está esculpido a mano.
Mucha gente piensa, "Bueno, son ordenadores,
y está hecho por máquinas y cosas así".
Bueno, lo reproducen, pero los originales se hacen todos a mano.
Los hacen hombres y mujeres que creen mucho en su habilidad.
Y ponen el mismo tipo de tensión en la escultura de un coche
que la que pones en una gran escultura que irías a ver a un museo.
Esa tensión entre la necesidad de expresar, la necesidad de descubrir,
luego pones algo nuevo en ello,
y a la vez tienes limites técnicos.
Reglas que dicen, así es como manipulas superficies,
esto es de lo que trata el control, así es como demuestras que eres un maestro de tu oficio.
Y esa tensión, ese descubrimiento, ese empuje hacia algo nuevo --
y al mismo tiempo, ese sentido de respeto
a las consideraciones técnicas --
que es tan fuerte en los coches como lo es en cualquier otra cosa.
Trabajamos en barro, que no ha cambiado mucho
desde que Miguel Ángel empezó a juguetear con él,
y hay una analogía muy interesante con eso también.
Muy rápido -- Miguel Ángel dijo una vez que estaba ahí para "descubrir la figura en el interior", ¿de acuerdo?
Ahí vamos, el automóvil.
Eso fue hace 100 años nada menos, ¿os disteis cuenta?
Entre ese de allí, y este otro de ahí, han cambiado un montón ¿verdad?
De acuerdo, no es marketing, hay un concepto de coche muy interesante aquí,
pero la parte de marketing no es de lo que quiero hablar aquí.
Quiero hablar de esto.
¿Por qué supone que hay que lavar un coche, qué es, esa sensualidad
acerca de ello que tienes que tocar? Esa es la escultura que lleva dentro. Esa sensualidad.
Y lo hacen hombres y mujeres trabajando de esta manera, haciendo coches.
Ahora esta pequeña cita de Henry Moore sobre la escultura,
creo que esa "presión interna" de la que Moore está hablando --
al menos en lo que se refiere a los coches --
vuelve directamente a esta idea del medio.
Es esa voluntad de vivir, esa necesidad de sobrevivir, de expresarse a sí mismo,
que viene con un coche, y se apodera de gente como yo.
Y le decimos a otra gente, "Haz esto, haz esto, haz esto", hasta que esta cosa toma vida.
Estamos completamente contagiados. Y la belleza puede ser el resultado
de este contagio, es bastante maravilloso.
Esta escultura está, por supuesto, en el centro de todo,
y es realmente lo que pone la artesanía en nuestros coches.
Y no es muy diferente, en realidad, cuando están trabajando de este modo,
o cuando alguien trabaja de este modo.
Es el mismo tipo de compromiso, el mismo tipo de belleza.
Bien, vale, voy al grano. Quiero hablar de los coches como arte.
El Arte, en el sentido platónico, es verdad, es belleza, y amor.
Ahora aquí es donde realmente los diseñadores en el negocio de los coches se separan de los ingenieros.
No tenemos en realidad problemas para hablar de amor.
No tenemos problemas para hablar de la verdad o la belleza en ese sentido.
Eso es lo que estamos buscando --
cuando estamos trabajando en nuestro oficio, estamos en realidad tratando de encontrar la verdad ahí fuera.
No estamos tratando de encontrar vanidad y belleza.
Estamos tratando de encontrar la belleza en la verdad.
Por el contrario, los ingenieros tienden a mirar las cosas de un modo más newtoniano,
en lugar de este enfoque cuántico.
Estamos tratando con cosas irracionales,
y estamos tratando con paradojas que admitimos que existen,
y los ingenieros tienden a mirar las cosas un poco más como
dos más dos son cuatro, y si obtienes 4.0 es mejor, y 4.0000 es todavía mejor.
Y eso a veces lleva a una cierta divergencia
en por qué hacemos lo que hacemos.
Hemos aceptado en gran medida, no obstante, el hecho
de que somos las mujeres en la organización de BMW --
BMW es un tipo de negocio muy masculino, -- hombres, hombres, hombres, son ingenieros.
Y somos un poco el lado femenino de eso. Está bien,
es estupendo, tú vas y eres masculino, nosotros vamos a ser un poco más femeninos.
Porque lo que nos interesa es encontrar forma que sea más que una simple función.
Estamos interesados en encontrar belleza que sea más que una simple estética,
que sea en realidad una verdad.
Y creo que esta idea del alma, como corazón de los grandes coches,
es muy aplicable. Todos lo sabéis. Reconocéis un coche cuando lo habéis visto,
con alma. Sabéis lo fuerte que es esto.
Bien, esta experiencia del amor, y la experiencia del diseño, para mí,
son intercambiables. Y ahora llego a mi historia.
Descubrí algo acerca del amor y el diseño a través de un proyecto llamado Deep Blue.
Y lo primero de todo, tenéis que seguirme durante un segundo, y decir,
sabes, podrías quitar la palabra amor de un montón de cosas en nuestra sociedad,
poner la palabra diseño en su lugar, y seguiría funcionando,
como esta cita de aquí, sabes. Más o menos funciona, ¿sabes?
Puedes entender eso. Funciona en perogrulladas.
"Todo está permitido en el diseño y en la guerra".
Por supuesto que vivimos en una sociedad competitiva.
Creo que esta de aquí, hay una canción pop
que para mí describe verdaderamente a Philippe Starck, sabes, es como,
sabes, es como el cariño hacia un cachorro, sabes, esto está bien ¿no?
Cepillo de dientes, estupendo.
Sólo se vuelve serio cuando miras a algo como esto, ¿de acuerdo?
(Risas)
Esta es una sustitución de la que creo
que todos nosotros, en la gestión del diseño, somos culpables.
Y esta idea de que hay más que amar,
más que diseñar, cuando llega hasta tu vecino, tu otro,
puede ser física como esto, y puede que en el futuro lo sea.
Pero ahora mismo es en el trato con nuestra propia gente,
nuestros propios equipos que están creando. Así que, a mi historia.
Aquí abordamos la idea de trabajo en equipo
y tengo que establecer lazos con mis diseñadores cuando estamos creando BMWs.
Tenemos que tener una intimidad compartida, una visión compartida
Lo que quiere decir que tenemos que trabajar como una familia,
tenemos que vernos a nosotros mismos de ese modo.
Hay momentos buenos, momentos interesantes,
y también momentos estresantes.
Quieres hacer coches, tienes que salir afuera.
Tienes que hacer coches bajo la lluvia, tienes que hacer coches en la nieve.
Esa, por cierto, es una presentación que hicimos a nuestra junta de directores.
Arrastramos sus traseros hasta la nieve también. ¿Quieres conocer a los coches en el exterior?
Bien, tienes que estar en el exterior para ello.
Y dado que estos son artistas, tienen temperamentos muy artísticos.
¿De acuerdo? Bien una cosa sobre el arte es, el arte es descubrimiento,
y el arte es descubrirte a ti mismo a través de tu arte. ¿Verdad?
Y una cosa sobre los coches es que todos somos un poco como Pigmalión,
estamos completamente enamorados de nuestras creaciones.
Esta es una de mis pinturas favoritas, describe verdaderamente nuestra relación con los coches.
Esto es increíblemente morboso.
(Risas)
Pero debido a esto, la intimidad con la que trabajamos juntos como equipo
adquiere una nueva dimensión, un nuevo significado.
Tenemos un centro compartido, tenemos un foco común,
de que el coche permanece en el centro de todas nuestras relaciones.
Y es mi trabajo, en el proceso competitivo, limitar esto.
Hoy escuché hablar de los genes de la muerte de Joseph
que tienen que entrar y matar la reproducción de las células.
Sabes, es lo que tengo que hacer a veces.
Empezamos con diez coches, lo reducimos a cinco,
a tres coches, a dos coches, a un coche,
y yo estoy en el medio de esa matanza, básicamente.
El amor de alguien, el bebé de alguien.
Esto es muy difícil, y tienes que tener un vínculo con tu equipo
que te permite hacerlo, porque su vida está también contenida en ello.
Tienen ese gen contagiado dentro de ellos también,
y quieren que viva, más que cualquier otra cosa.
Bien, este proyecto, Deep Blue me puso en contacto con mi equipo
de un modo que nunca esperé, y quiero compartirlo con vosotros,
porque quiero que reflexionéis sobre esto, tal vez en vuestras propias relaciones.
Queríamos hacer un coche que fuese un completo acto de fe para BMW.
Queríamos crear un equipo que estuviese tan alejado del modo en que lo habíamos hecho,
que sólo tenía un número de teléfono que me conectaba a ellos.
Así que, lo que hicimos fue que en lugar de tener a un grupo de artistas que son básicamente tu muñeca,
decidimos liberar un equipo de diseñadores creativos e ingenieros
para encontrar el suceso del fenómeno 4x4 en EE.UU.
Es en 1996 cuando hicimos este proyecto. Así que los enviamos con su nombre de equipo,
Deep Blue. Ahora mucha gente conoce Deep Blue por IBM,
en realidad lo robamos de ellos porque pensamos
que si alguien leía nuestros faxes pensarían que estábamos hablando de ordenadores.
Resultó ser bastante inteligente porque Deep Blue,
en una compañía como BMW, tiene gancho -- Deep Blue, guau, buen nombre.
Así que la gente se involucró en él. Y cogimos a un equipo de diseñadores,
y los enviamos a EE.UU. Y les dimos un presupuesto,
lo que pensamos que era un conjunto de entregas,
un calendario, y nada más.
Como dije, sólo tenía un número de teléfono que me conectaba a ellos.
Y un grupo de ingenieros trabajando en Alemania,
y la idea era que trabajarían separadamente
en este problema de cuál es el sucesor del vehículo deportivo utilitario,
se juntarían, compararían notas. Entonces volverían a trabajar separados,
a juntarse, y juntos producirían
un conjunto monumental de opiniones diversas que no contaminasen las ideas de los otros --
pero que a la vez se uniesen y resolviesen los problemas.
Siendo optimista, entender de verdad al cliente a fondo,
dónde está el cliente, vivir con ellos en EE.UU. Así que -- enviamos al equipo,
y en realidad ocurrió algo diferente. Fueron a otros sitios.
(Risas)
Desaparecieron, francamente, y todo lo que recibía eran postales.
Bien, tengo algunas postales de esta gente en Las Vegas,
y tengo algunas postales de esta gente en el Gran Cañón,
y tengo estas postales de las cataratas del Niágara,
y enseguida están en Nueva York, y no sé dónde más.
Y me digo a mí mismo, "Este va a ser un gran coche,
están haciendo investigación en la que nunca antes habría pensado".
¿Verdad? Y decidieron que, en lugar de, por ejemplo, tener un estudio,
y seis o siete apartamentos,
era más barato alquilar la antigua casa de Elizabeth Taylor en Malibu.
Y -- por lo menos me dijeron que era su casa,
creo que una vez, celebró una fiesta allí o algo.
Pero de todos modos, esta era la casa, y todos ellos vivían allí.
Y así vivían todo el tiempo, media docena de personas que habían dejado --
algunos habían dejado a sus mujeres y a sus familias,
y literalmente vivieron en esta casa
durante los seis meses completos que el proyecto estuvo en EE.UU.,
pero los primeros tres meses fueron los más intensivos.
Y una de las chicas en el proyecto,
era una mujer fantástica, de verdad construyó su habitación en el baño.
El baño era tan grande, que construyó su cama sobre la bañera --
es bastante fascinante.
Por otra parte, yo no sabía nada de todo esto, ¿de acuerdo?
Nada. Todo esto está ocurriendo, y todo lo que recibo son postales
de esta gente en Las Vegas, o lo que sea,
diciendo, "No te preocupes Chris, esto va a ser bueno de verdad". ¿Vale?
Así que mi concepto de lo que era un estudio de diseño probablemente --
No había llegado a dónde esta gente estaba.
Sin embargo, los ingenieros allá en Múnich
habían adoptado este tipo de solución newtoniana,
y estaban tratando de descubrir cuántos soportes para vasos
pueden bailar en la cabeza de un alfiler, y, sabéis,
estas preguntas realmente importantes a las que se enfrenta el consumidor moderno.
Y uno esperaba que estos dos equipos se juntasen,
y esta colisión de creatividad increíble,
en este entorno increíble,
y estos ingenieros increíblemente estresados,
crearían algunas soluciones increíbles.
Bien, lo que yo no sabía, y lo que descubrimos fue...
que esta gente, ni siquiera pueden hablar entre ellos en estas condiciones.
Tienes una divergencia del pensamiento cuántico y newtoniano en ese punto,
tienes una fractura en el diálogo que es tan profunda, y tan lejana,
que no pueden unir todo esto de ninguna manera.
Así que tuvimos nuestra primera reunión, después de tres meses, en Tiburón,
que está un poco más arriba de aquí por la carretera -- ¿conocéis Tiburón?
Y la idea era que después de los tres primeros meses de esta investigación independiente
presentarían todo al Dr. Goschel
(que ahora es mi jefe, y que en aquella época era mi co-mentor en el proyecto)
y que presentarían sus resultados.
Veríamos hacía donde estábamos yendo,
veríamos el primer indicio de lo que podría ser
el fenómeno sucesor del 4x4 en EE.UU.
Así que tenía estas ideas en mi cabeza, que esto iba a ser genial.
Quiero decir, voy a ver tanto trabajo, es tan intenso --
sé que probablemente Las Vegas tuvo un montón de importancia,
y no estoy del todo seguro donde entra el Gran Cañón tampoco --
pero de algún modo todo esto se va a unir,
y voy a ver algún producto realmente genial.
Así que fuimos a Tiburón, después de tres meses,
y el equipo se había juntado la semana anterior,
bastantes días antes de tiempo.
Los ingenieros volaron allí, y los diseñadores se reunieron con ellos,
y juntos prepararon su presentación.
Bien, resulta que los ingenieros no habían hecho nada.
Y no habían hecho nada porque --
un poco, digamos que en el negocio de los coches, los ingenieros están ahí para resolver problemas,
y les estábamos pidiendo que creasen un problema.
Y los ingenieros estaban esperando a que los diseñadores dijesen,
"Este es el problema que hemos creado, ahora ayudadnos a resolverlo".
Y no pudieron hablar de ello. Así que lo que sucedió fue,
que los ingenieros aparecieron sin nada.
Y los ingenieros le dijeron a los diseñadores,
"Si entráis con todo lo vuestro, nos vamos,
abandonamos directamente el proyecto".
Así que yo no sabía nada de todo esto,
y tuvimos una presentación que tenía una agenda, que tenía este aspecto.
Hubo mucho diálogo.
Nos pasamos cuatro horas escuchando todo acerca del vocabulario
que necesita crearse entre ingenieros y diseñadores.
Y yo aquí esperando que en cualquier momento, "Bien, van a pasar la página,
y voy a ver los coches, voy a ver los bocetos,
voy a ver tal vez una idea de a dónde se dirige".
La conversación seguía adelante, con mapas mentales de palabras, y bastante pronto
se estaba volviendo obvio que en lugar de ser deslumbrado por la brillantez,
estaba siendo seriamente distraído con minucias.
Y os podéis imaginar lo que es esto,
tener todos estos meses de indicaciones por postales de lo bien que este equipo está trabajando,
y están ahí fuera gastando todo este dinero, y están aprendiendo,
y están haciendo todas estas cosas.
Me enfadé mucho, ¿vale? Me volví loco.
Probablemente podéis recordar Tiburón, solía tener este aspecto.
Después de cuatro horas de esto, me levanté, e hice pedazos a este equipo.
Les abronqué, les grité, "¿Qué demonios estáis haciendo?
Me estáis decepcionando, sois mis diseñadores,
se supone que tenéis que ser los creativos,
¿qué coño está pasando aquí?"
Fue probablemente una de mis mejores broncas, tengo algunas buenas,
pero esta probablemente fue una de las mejores. Y le dije a esta gente;
¿cómo podían coger el dinero de BMW,
cómo podían tomarse tres meses de vacaciones y no tener nada, nada?
Porque por supuesto no nos dijeron que tenían tres furgonetas
llenas de dibujos, modelos de prototipos, fotos -- todo lo que quería
lo habían guardado en los coches, porque habían mostrado solidaridad con los ingenieros --
y habían decidido no enseñarme nada,
para darle a la oportunidad de resolver los problemas una oportunidad de comenzar,
porque no se habían dado cuenta, por supuesto,
que no podían crear problemas.
Así que nos fuimos a comer --
(Risas)
Y tengo que deciros, fue una comida tremendamente silenciosa.
Los ingenieros se sentaron todos en un extremo de la mesa,
los diseñadores y yo nos sentamos en el otro extremo de la mesa, muy silenciosos.
Y yo estaba furioso de la hostia, furioso. ¿Vale?
Probablemente porque ellos habían disfrutado de toda la diversión y yo no, sabéis.
Eso es por lo que te enfadas ¿no?
Y alguien me preguntó por Catherine, mi mujer, sabes,
¿había venido conmigo o algo así?
Dije, "No", y eso provocó una serie de pensamientos sobre mi mujer.
Y me acordé que cuando Catherine y yo nos casamos,
el cura dio un sermón muy bonito, y dijo algo muy importante.
Dijo, "El amor no es egoísta", dijo,
"El amor no se trata de contar cuantas veces digo,'Te quiero'.
No se trata de que hayas tenido sexo tantas veces este mes,
y que sea dos veces menos que el mes pasado,
así que eso significa que no me quieres tanto.
El amor no es egoísta". Y pensé sobre esto, y pensé,
"Sabes, no estoy demostrando amor aquí. De verdad que no estoy demostrando amor.
Estoy en el aire, estoy en el aire sin confianza.
Esto no puede ser. No puede ser que esté esperando un cierto número de bocetos,
y que para mí ese sea el método de medir la calidad de un equipo.
Esto no puede ser".
Así que les conté esta historia. Dije, "Chicos, estoy aquí pensando en algo,
esto no está bien. No puedo tener una relación con vosotros
basada en una premisa que es cuantificable.
Basada en una premisa impuesta que dice, "Soy un jefe, haced lo que diga, sin confianza".
Dije "Esto no puede ser".
En realidad, todos nos pusimos a llorar, para ser sincero,
porque todavía no podían contarme cuanta frustración habían acumulado
dentro, sin ser capaces de enseñarme lo que quería,
y teniendo simplemente que pedirme que confiase en ellos, que llegaría.
Y creo que nos sentimos mucho más cercanos ese día,
cortamos un montón de hilos que no tenían por qué estar ahí,
y fraguamos el concepto de lo que en realidad significan el equipo y la creatividad.
Pusimos el coche de nuevo en el centro de nuestros pensamientos, y pusimos amor,
creo, realmente de nuevo en el centro del proceso.
Por cierto, ese equipo acabó creando seis prototipos diferentes
para el siguiente modelo de lo que sería la propuesta
de la nueva generación posterior a las 4x4 en EE.UU.
Una de ellas era la idea de las coupés crossover...
podéis verlo abajo, el X Coupe, se lo pasaron muy bien con eso.
Era la interpretación de nuestra motocicleta,
la GS, como solía decir Carl Magnusson, "brutermosa"
como idea de lo que podía ser una motocicleta, si le añades dos ruedas más.
Así que, para concluir, mi lección que quería transmitiros a vosotros,
era esta de aquí. También voy a robar una pequeña cita de "El Principito".
Hay mucho que decir acerca de la confianza y el amor,
si sabes que esas dos palabras son sinónimos de diseño.
Tuve una relación muy, muy significativa con mi equipo aquel día,
y se ha mantenido así desde entonces.
Y espero que vosotros también descubráis que hay más en el diseño,
y más para con el arte del diseño, que hacerlo uno mismo.
Es cierto que la confianza y el amor, que hacen que merezca la pena.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)